لم نعد بحاجه لمساعدات قالها احد الناشطين
في ريف ادلب فمن قاتل للبقاء على قيد
الحياه تحت الانقاض من الصعب ان يصمد
اربعه ايام لم نعد بحاجه لمساعدات فمعابر
تركيا اغلقت بوجهنا ومبررات اغلاقها وهي
يقول السوريون المحاصرون اما الامم
المتحده فسارعت لارسال المساعدات على طرق
رسمتها موسكو وتؤدي كلها الى دمشق في
نهايه المطاف تقول فرن بوليسي المجله
الامريكيه في وصفها لما حدث يبدو ان
العالم اعتاد معاناه السوريين فلم يفكر
بهم او يهتم لامرهم فاعطى اولويه
المساعدات لتركيا تغطيه مستمره مع تجاوز
اعداد القتلى 21 في سوريا وتركيا
سلام اخير وداع من تحت الانقاض خيبه تلو
الاخرى ركام لا يلفظ الا الجسد والقليل من
الحياه صباح اخر والكارثه تتوسع وتضيق
فيها فرص النجاه
يتفقد هذا الرجل الحطام محاوله متعثره
للبحث عن عائلته ابتلعت الانقاض ما لا يقل
عن 17 من افراد اسرته حتى الان لم تسعفه
ذاكرته حتى بعد ان جفت الدموع قال لك
روحنا اخوي
ونسوان اثنين معه
ايش قد احمد تقريبا شي 17 واحد
كارثه مدويه
تحايل عليها المنقذون على امل سماع من
يطلب النجاه
صوت من بطن الارض هذا المراد لا غير
تسير عمليات الانقاذ بلا توقف وبحسب خبراء
الفتره الذهبيه لانقاذ الارواح في مثل هذه
الكوارث شارفت على الانتهاء ونقص الغذاء
وطقس البارد عاملان توفرهما يزيد المشهد
مراره
الاطفال الاوفر حظا في النجاه رغم وفاه
الالاف منهم لكن ما ينتظرهم مقلق وفق
اليونيسف غالبيه الاطفال ينجون دون
عائلاتهم ما يعمق من ازمه الطفوله
المفقوده في سوريا طوال السنين الماضيه
ضحايا كارثه الزلزال يقترب عددهم من
العشرين الف قتيل في سوريا وتركيا راحوا
جميعهم في حادثه تزلزلت فيها الارض ودكت
من عليها
غذاء السالم العربيه
اللي صار فينا منام
لا اله الا الله وصلت على الدرجه تحت قلبت
فينا البنايه انا من هون من تحت السقف
تحتي ضليت كم ساعه عيط عيط عيط بعدين سكتت
اشهدت اخر نفس واحد لحتى سمعني بس انا
شايفه جوزي تحت السقف وفي اولاد جسس فوقي
في شو اسمه
في اولاد كتير فوقي كانوا
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش
ضللي واحد تروح انت
نادي اخواته
راح ادوس صلاه الفجر
شو بده يصير اكثر من هيك يا عمي شو بده
يصير
من مدينه سرمدا شمال ادلب منير المصطفى
نائب مدير الدفاع المدني سوريا انضم الينا
استاذ منير اهلا بك معنا طبعا هذا هو
اليوم الرابع الامال بدات تتضاءل بايجاد
احياء ولكن هل يمكن ان تصف لنا الاوضاع
اين وصلت عمليات الانقاذ واين تتركز
نعم في الحقيقه لرابع يوم على التوالي
عمليات الانقاذ لا زالت مستمره حتى الان
والان تتركز في اكثر المدن تضررا في شمال
غرب سوريا منها مدينه جنديرس مدينه حارم
مدينه سلقين مدينه عزمارين مدينه مدينه
بسنيا هذه هي المناطق التي لا تزال فرق
البحث في الانقاذ يعني تعمل على استخراج
العالقين من تحت الانقاذ ولكن اي احياء
اليوم استاذ منير
هلا حقيقه نحن نعتمد على بعض المعلومات
الوارده من المدنيين على اقاريرهم او
اصدقائهم او جيرانهم ولكن هذه الارقام
اكيد هي ليست ارقام نهائيه ولا يمكن ان
نعتمد عليها بشكل كامل او بشكل مباشر
استطعنا ان ننتشل 2030 قتيل حتى هذه
اللحظه من تحت الانقاض استوقعنا ان ننقذ
2950 شخص حتى هذه اللحظه من تحت الانقاب
ولكن اعداد القتلى للاسف هي مرشحه للزياده
بشكل بشكل كبير في هذه الساعات يعني نحن
نقترب من اليوم نهايه اليوم الرابع
الحاله الجويه والبرد يعني هو شديد صراحه
وهذا ما يزيد معاناه الاشخاص
المتواجدين تحت الانقاضي عن الشخص المصاب
الذي تعرض الى نزيف او تعرض الى هرس وفوق
ذلك درجات حراره وخاصه بالليل تكون درجات
حراره متدنيه جدا والجسم عندما يفقد من
الدماء شيء فهو يبرد بحد ذاته فاذا فرض
ايضا في هذا الطقس صراحه تكون فرص الحياه
ضعيفه جدا للاسف في وضع المستشفيات استاذ
منير هناك هل الطاقم الطبي كافي هل معدات
طبيه متوفره
في الحقيقه نحن منذ بدايه الازمه ايضا منذ
بدايه هذا الزلزال توجهنا نحن مباشره
لمناشدات من اجل دعم الاطقم الطبيه ما
المشافي كلها مستنفره بالكامل الطبيه
مستنفره بالكامل
المستوصفات مستنفره بالكامل ولكن طاقتها
الاستيعابيه وقدرتها على استيعابها مثل
هذه الكوارث صراحه هي قدره محدوده واصلا
جزء من هذه المشافي تعرض للضرر جزء منها
اصلا معطل وغير قادر على استقبال احد بسبب
الضرر الذي لحق في بنيه هذا المشفى يعني
الزلزال اخذ يعني نال من العديد من النقاط
الطبيه والمشافي التي هي بالاساس تكاد
يعني تستطيع ان تستقبل في الحالات العاديه
ان تكون هي كافيه للمناطق التي هي موجود
فيها يعني اليوم من الاخبار الجيده بانه
بدات المساعدات بالدخول الى شمال السوري
هل ضمن هذه المساعدات هناك وعود ان تصل
لكم معدات ورا لمساعدتكم في رفع الانقاض
صراحه انا ارى هذا الخبر من ناحيه اخرى
يعني دخلت اليوم ست شاحنات هي شاحنات مخطط
لها ان تدخل قبل ان يحصل هذا الزلزال دخلت
عن طريق معبر باب الهوى عن طريق الامم
المتحده وهي مخطط لها لانه اصلا هو معبر
انساني معتمد عند الامم المتحده نحن هناك
وعود بوصول اليات اكيد ثقيله تساعد فرق
البحث والانقاذ ولكن كنا ننادي ونناشد ان
تكون مبكر اكثر من هذا حتى تساعدنا بسحب
العالقين وهم احياء لا نريد ان نسحب من
تحت الانقاط او ننتشر الجثث يعني حقيقه
اذا وصلت يعني غدا او بعد غد او يعني
بفتره يعني بعد الان سيكون
لسحب الجثث وليس لسحب العالقين الاحياء
للاسف شكرا لك من مدينه سرمدا شمال ادلب
مدير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدنيه
السوريه على هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
في تركيا وسوريا الكثير من القصص الحزينه
واحده منها لرجل خمس سنين في قهرمان مرعش
فقد الكثير ولم يعد يعرف كيف يتصرف في
واقعه الجديد نتابع
[موسيقى]
رجل تركي تجاوز الخمسين من عمره كغيره من
الملايين ترك فيه الزلزال ندبه لن تختفي
[موسيقى]
جلس هانسر قرب مبنى متهدم في قهرمان مرعش
ممسكا بيد ممتده من بين الانقاض يد طفلته
التي ماتت عن خمسه عشره سنه
يرفض ان يتركها وسط الدمار يقول ادم التان
مصور وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه الذي وثق
الماساه ان الاب المكلوم همس له قائلا
التقط صوره لطفلتي ثم بقي ساكنا لساعات
يحدق في العدم
يتشبث بيدي فقيدته غير مبال بالبرد والمطر
ويضيف المصور هذا الالم لا يطاق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا تركل يتركل يلا يلا
في مختلف المناطق التركيه متواجدين هناك
الان ينضم الي من قهرمان مرعش غسان ابو
لوز مفرد العربيه من اذيه
اهلا بكما غسان سابدا معك تعد هذه المنطقه
هي الاكثر تضررا في هذا الزلزال في تركيا
الاوضاع سيئه ما هي مشاهداتك
نعم بالفعل ميسون الاكثر تضررا وهي
المنطقه المنكوبه في جنوب تركيا نظرا
لانها كانت مركز الزلزال وبالتالي هنا
الوضع سيء جدا هنا ما زالت عمليات الاغاثه
والانقاذ مستمره حتى هذه الساعه نحن على
مشارف اليوم الخامس وما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ المستمره كما تشاهدين من خلفي هذا
شارع فيه يعني
عشرات المباني ميسون منهاره تماما وكما
تشاهدين الاليات ما زالت تعمل على ازاله
هذه الانقاض وما زال يعني عناصر فرق
الانقاذ يحاولون الوصول الى عالقين تحت
هذه الانقط طبعا لا توجد اعداد رسميه او
تقديريه حتى ميسون لعدد العالقين تحت
الانقاض هنا في هذا الشارع ميسون خلال
الساعات الماضيه تم انتشال تقريبا خمس تم
عفوا تم انقاذ خمس اشخاص كانوا على قيد
الحياه وتم انقاذهم
ونقلهم الى
المستشفيات لتقديم
العلاج اللازم وكما تشاهدين ايضا ميسون
على في هذا المبنى هذا المبنى يعني جزء
منه منهار وجزء والاخر يقف لكنه ايل
للسقوط في اي لحظه وبالتالي هذا
الانقاذ التي
تعمل في هذا الشارع في احد شوارع مدينه
كهرمان مرعش ايضا هناك على الطرف الاخر
مباني مدمره وفي المنتصف في منتصف هذا
الشارع
هناك عائلات ما زالت تجلس هنا على امل ان
يعني ان يكون هناك خبر مفرح غسان هذا
الامل هل هو مقرون بوقائع هل يسمع بعض
اصوات في هذه المباني
لا اصوات حتى الان لانه بالامس في بعض
المباني كنا نتابع فيها هذه العمليات
عمليات الانقاذ كان يقال بان هناك بعض
الاصوات ما زالت تسمع هل في هذا المبنى
حيث انت هذا الامل موجود هل هذه المؤشرات
موجوده
نعم بالفعل ميسون قبل عناصر الانقاذ
ابلغنا على الاقل يوجد فيه عشره اشخاص
وقالوا انهم سمعوا اصوات وبالتالي هم
يواصلون في نقطه محدده معينه في محاوله
للعثور على هؤلاء وبالتالي هم يقولون ان
هناك ما زال ناجين تحت هذه الانقاض لكنهم
يواصلون عمليه
الحفر وازاله هذه الانقاض للوصول اليهم لا
يوجد لديهم اي تقديرات
زمنيه متى يمكن ان يصلوا لان العمليه
الانقاذ والازاله معقده جدا ميسون تتحدثين
عن الاف الاطنان من الركام وبالتالي اي
تحرك خاطئ من الاليات او من الممكن ان
يتسبب في تحريك هذه الانقاض وانهيارها من
جديد على
العالقين في اسفل هذه الانقاذ هذا بالنسبه
معوقات غسان شارع ميسون اخبروكم بها يعني
من يقومون بعمليات الانقاذ امور بالنسبه
لهم يعني كل شيء مؤمن من رافعات من معدات
حديثه خاصه التي تستشعر يعني اذا كان هناك
من اوكسجين مثلا في هذه الابنيه اذا كان
هناك من احياء في هذه الابنيه هل كل متوفر
في قهرمان مرعش
متوفر ميسون فقط اريد الاشاره الى ان هناك
مباني اخرى يوجد فيها
اشخاص عالقين اكدوا لنا عناصر الانقاذ
بانهم على قيد الحياه تحدثوا عن خمس اشخاص
في مبنى وثلاث اشخاص في مبنى اخر ما زالوا
على قيد الحياه بينهم اطفال وما زالوا
يواصلون عمليه الانقاذ للوصول الى هؤلاء
ميسون اسمحيلي فقط هنا احد الاشخاص
معنا ممكن ان نتحدث معه اكيد ممكن بس تحكي
لنا ما الذي جرى معكم بالضبط اخي الكريم
بدايه
الساعه الرابعه 17 دقيقه تقريبا
فحصل زلزال زلزال كان رهيب جدا جدا البناء
الابنيه اصبحت الطاير بشكل فعلي الحمد لله
اكثر من دقيقه دقيقه ونصف
ثم انتهت اول اول هزه
اين كنت فيها بالبيت
يعني حوالي نصف ساعه داخل على البيت فحصل
الزلزال
كل الاهالي نزلت الى الشارع فلما نزلنا
تفاجانا بالاعداد الكبيره من الابنيه اللي
ساقطه على الارض والناس عم تصرخ من تحت
الابنيه ساعدونا ان كانت المنطقه المتهمه
غالبيه السكان هنا سوريين
لاني هون المنطقه هلا احد هذا البناء
حاليا بهذا البناء اربعه ايام محسن
اطالعون بيت اختي في الحاله الخلفيه
الحمد لله اخرجناها بعد ثمان ساعات خرجوا
سالمين الحمد لله
اما يعني
اعداد جدا كبيره اللي توفت من سوريا هل من
معلومات عن اخيك حتى هذا ابدا للاسف يعني
ولا احنا نحسن نسمع صوته نهائيا عم نستنى
حاليا الحفارات مثل مانك شايف شغاله كم
عمره اخوك 37 سنه مهندس معماري عمره 37
سنه عايش هو وبنته هون
بنته اخرجناه الحمد لله فقط الاب بقي كيف
وضع بنت اخوه السالمي الحمد لله
عز وجل
الحمد لله حاليا الامدادات اجت بشكل كبير
يعني والمساعدات والحمد لله نعمل من الله
عز وجل انه اليوم بالليل نحسن نحاول اين
تقيم الان اين تقيمون
تقريبا انتشروا في كل الولايات عن نفسي
انا اخذت اهلي وعيالي كلن تقريبا حاليا
برقنا في مستودع قريب من البلد
[موسيقى]
يعني طبعا نعتذر من رداءه الصوت من المصدر
لانه
بسبب هذا الزلزال البنيه التحتيه تاثرت
او اتصالات
غسان غسان لم نكن نسمع كان انقطع الاتصال
انقطع الصوت معك اسمح لي ان اذهب الى اديه
مان لنتابع مع محمود شكر محمود اهلا بك
معنا موفد العربيه الى اديه مان اين انت
متواجد الان وماذا يمكن ان تطلعنا على
المساعدات التي تقدم حيث انت
عزيزتي ميسون نحن نتواجد في البهو الخارجي
لهذه الجامعه التي هي الجامعه الام لهذه
المدينه كما اشرت تحولت الى مركز لوجستي
وايضا مركز للبعثات الخارجيه التي وصلت
وايضا مركز ان كان لكل المساعدات العينيه
وغير العينيه والطبيه وايضا كمطبخ في
الخلف يقدم الوجبات الغذائيه الساخنه
للالف ولكن ساذهب سريعا لاستفيد من حضور
الرئيس
العميد
العميد طارق طارق رئيس فريق البحث
والانقاذ التونسي الموجود هنا في تركيا
لمده المساعده للشعب التركي
خليني اذهب معك سريعا لنستفيد من حضورك
الان عندكم فرق تعمل على الارض داخل
المدينه حاليا ان فرق تعمل على الارض داخل
مدينه تقوم بالبحث وانتشال المصابين الى
الموتى من تحت الانقاذ العمل متاعنا
المتوسط لمده 24 ساعه يتوقف عن الفرق
ميدانيه قبه عمل بينها فيما بينها قاعده
ميدانيه موجوده هنا في مقر الجامعه
عمليه التدخل والبحث مع محطه العميد كم من
ناسين اثرتم عليهم حتى الساعه
خمسه اخرين بعدين نخدم عليهم ان شاء الله
عندكم معلومات دقيقه مع القياده التركيه
عن اعداد الذين تحت الارقام في هذه
المدينه احنا قاعدين نسقم القياده التركيه
الموجوده هنا في المدينه هذه مع الجيش
الموجوده هناخذ المعطيات منهم هم من
المتسكرين اللي عندهم عقارب فيكي باش
نحددو تقريبا الاعداد اللي نخدموا عليه
باش اذا كان خرجنا بعد الحسنى
ضحيه اخرى موجود تحت نقال العدد نتحصلوا
عليها مع العداد
انت رئيس الحمايه المدنيه عندك خبره
عالميه هل انت راضي عن عمليات اللي كانت
جميله منذ بعض الوقت تسال في منطقه اخرى
عن المعدات عن القضايا التي تؤمن عنها هل
انت راضي يعني عن العمل في هذه المدينه من
جهه الفرق على الارض حاليا الفرق كره
القدم في الدعم والمجهودات الكبيره متاحه
فما تنسيق الاماكن شاسعه سيئه عدد المباني
المنهاره كبير برشا اللي يطلب جهد اكبر
ومضاعفات اكبر يعني هل عندكم الالات هي
موجوده معكم وكبعثات اخرى يعني في هنا
توجد البعثه الارمنيه وتوجد بعثه الجورجيه
انت كيف تقيم كمراقب
ركيزه بهذا العمل الفرق الكل قاعده تقوم
عند المعدات المتاحه وعند التعليقات البحث
والتقنيه الحديثه تعمل بها كيف كيف
مباشره
للعمل
في الحديث الكثير عن بقاء النجين حتى هذه
الساعه نحن ندخل في اليوم الخامس شو الوضع
بهاي النقطه هو العمل دائما موجود لكن
عوامل اخرى تخرج عن المصابين اللي هو
بروده الطقس طول المده الجوع على العطش
نوع العصابه لتعرض لها اللي ممكن تؤثر على
الحاله بتاعه وتقلص معناة أمل في وجودهم
موجود احنا عندنا معدات خاصه تبين اذا
تعطينا المكان والنبض ونخدمو عليه ان شاء
الله
يومين او اربع او خمسه يجوز هذا الامر
يجوز حتى اكثر حتى اكثر حسب الوضعيه حسب
المعطيات حسب الدوله المحليه اللي هي
تركيا في بقاء الفرق مثلا يكونوا احنا
فيقع تقليص شباب
على حضوركم على هذه المعلومات ميسون هذه
من الجهه نعم نعم اسمعك اسمعك محمود من
جهه الثانيه خليني اذهب خليني اذهب
للمساعدات ساذهب مباشره الى هذا الفان او
محمود قبل ان نبدا بالمساعدات هل يمكن ان
تعدد لنا من هي البعثات المتواجده هناك
الان تابعنا البعثه التونسيه من خلال
الكابيتان اللي كان مع حضرتك الان
وكنت ذكرت بانه
العميد ايضا كان هناك ذكرت انه هناك بعثه
ارمينيه هناك بعثه جورجيا من هي البعثات
المتواجده ايضا في اديه من حيث تتواجد
نعم في المخيم الذي نحن فيه والذي نصب هنا
توجد البعثه الارمنيه كما اشارتي والبعثه
الجورجي لا علم لنا خليني اذهب بس لاستفيد
من حضره العميد بهذه هل عندك معلومات عن
عدد البعثات الموجوده هنا غير الجورجيه
الارمنيه رايتها وانتم التونسيه هل هنالك
من بعثه اخرى بعثات اخرى التقطم بها ثم
البعث الاسبانيه وعند نزولنا في مطار
جزيره البعثه للكوريه الجنوبيه والبحث
الفرنسيه والبحث الالمانيه الان هنا في
الجزائريه الجزائريه هنا في هذه يعني نحن
نتحدث عن سته الى سبع بعثات في هذه
المدينه
نعم هل من اسئله ميسون بهذا الخصوص
وتحديدا
لا نريد الان نتابع معك المساعدات التي
تقدم في الديامان هل يمكن ان تتابعها معنا
محمود شكرا لك من جديد شكرا نعم
اذا اخذنا الصوره ايضا الى هذه المجموعه
من المتطوعات والمتطوعين سالناهم ماذا
تفعلون كان الجواب انه في هذا المخازن
توجد المساعدات التي تاتي من كل المحافظات
التركيه الى الجامعه هم يقومون الان
بتوزيع هذه المساعدات على عده انواع مثلا
في كل كرتونه ماذا يوجد فيها
معكرونه يوجد
طماطم ثم بعد ذلك
مواد غذائيه وهي في طريقها
الجل الاكبر كما شاهدنا هي من الاهل من
المنظمات الشعبيه ومن المنظمات الغير
حكوميه ومن المؤسسات الدينيه وهذا ما
شهدناه ليس في هذه في هذا المركز ولكن على
امتداد المدينه كنت قبل هذا المباشر
بمباشر اخر من امام خياب في العراء
للناجحين السوريين او في تجمعات ما ان
انتهينا من المباشر حتى اتت سيارات سالت
عن هذه السيارات واذ مدنيين من ابناء
البلده يعني مواطنين اتراك هم خرجوا
يحملون بايديهم الاكاس ويسالون من الاطفال
هذا خبز للاطفال من النسبه هذه حاجات
للنسوه هو مريض هذه حاجات هنالك تكافل
تضامن اجتماعي على مستوى عال جدا من
الاهتمام الانساني الاخوي في المدينه ولكن
هذا الاهتمام هو
غطى قضيه المواد الغذائيه وايضا لو كنا
دخلنا داخل لو كنت رايت المطبخ المجهز
الذي يقدم الوجبات الغذائيه منذ ثلاثه
ايام كان الهم اذهب الى غسان لانه
ايضا اخبار جديده
وللاسف اخبار سيئه يبدو هناك انتشال جثث
غسان اليك ماذا لديك من جديد
نعم بالفعل ميسون تم انتشال الان جثتين من
احد المباني خلفي ونقلها الى سياره
الاسعاف سنطلب من الزميل المصور باسل ان
يعني يدير الكاميرا الى هذا المشهد هؤلاء
الناس الان يقفون حول الجثتين التي تم
انتشالها وسيتم نقلها في
هذا الاسعاف للاسف يعني ما زالت الجثث
يعني الان ميسون حسب ما فهمت من الزميل
باسل بانه يتم التعرف على الجثث في هذه
الحاله بالفعل الجثث التي يتم انتشالها
يتم يعني جلب الناس او الاقارب الموجودين
والاهالي الموجودين للتعرفوا على الجثث في
حال تم التعرف على الجثث ميسون يتم دفنها
فورا اما الجثث المجهوله الهويه او التي
لا يتم التعرف عليها تبقى لمده 24 ساعه
ومن ثم تؤخذ عينات من الحمض النووي لهذه
الجثث
وتدفن بعد 24 ساعه وتبقى العينات الحمض
النووي حتى يتم التعرف عليها لاحقا
تتحدثين عن الالاف من القتلى وبالتالي لا
يمكنني لا يمكن ان ينتظروا اكثر من ذلك
وبالتالي يلجاون الى دفن هذه
الجثث سريعا
ميسون الانباء
ميسون ما زالت تتوالى وترى اتباعا من هذه
المنطقه التي نقف فيها على امل ان يكون
هناك
انباء مفرحه بخروج المزيد من الناجين من
تحت الانقاذ وكما قلنا قبل قليل بان هذا
المبنى يوجد فيه تقريبا عشره اشخاص يتوقع
المنقذون وعناصر الانقاذ ان يكون هناك
ناجين تحت هذه الانقاض وايضا في المباني
الاخرى على الجهه المقابله نتحدث عن شارع
بمئات الامتار ميسون كل معظم المباني هنا
مدمره ومنهاره ونتحدث ايضا عن عشرات
الاليات والمئات والاف عمال الانقاذ الذين
يواصلون العمل
ليلا نهارا وكنا نقول باننا على عتاب
اليوم الخامس
والحديث عن الايام التي تمر يعني صعب جدا
سواء كان على فرق الانقاذ او حتى على
الاهالي وعلى الجميع لان كل ساعه تمر
تتضاء الفرص ان جاء امام العالقين
امام
الناجين ان كان هناك ناجين تحت
الانقاذ
الاهالي كما تشاهدين موجودين في هذه هل
الكهرباء
في هذه المناطق
نعم بالفعل رئيس بلديه كهرمان مرعش قال
بان البنيه التحتيه في هذه المدينه مدمره
تماما ميسون لا يوجد كهرباء في هذه
المدينه وبالتالي هنا عمال الانقاذ وفرق
الانقاذ تلجا الى المولدات مولدات الطاقه
والكهرباء للاستعانه بها هذه المدينه
منكوبه بالفعل المنكوبه ميسون قبل قليل لا
ادري انقطع الاتصال معكم ولا ادري ان كان
يعني استمعتم الى احد الاشخاص وهو سوري
الجنسيه الجنسيه يقول بانه لديه اخ في ذلك
المبنى
لا يدري حتى اللحظه ان كان على قيد الحياه
ام لا وهو ينتظر
يعني ايه انباء عن اخيه كانت معه ابنته
لكنها لحسن الحظ استطاعت الهروب
والخروج من هذا المنزل او لا بالاحرى قال
لي بانهم
ينقذوها بعد ثمان ساعات من انهيار هذا
المبنى اما اخيه ما زال موجودا وايضا تحدث
عن زوجه اخيه او اقارب له في مبنى اخر في
هذا الشارع وقال بان هذا الشارع معظم
المباني او اغلب المباني في هذا الشارع
ميسون هي قديمه جدا يعني احدث بناء عمره
30 سنه
وهذا ما يفسر حجم الدمار الهائل في هذا
الشارع وفي مدينه كهرمان مرعش وهو
الذين كانوا يعيشون في هذه الاحياء غسان
ميسون تم اجلائهم الى مخيمات طوارئ تم
اجلائهم الى مراكز ايواء الى مدارس الى
صلاه رياضيه الى فنادق في مناطق اخرى
بعيده عن هذه المناطق هم يخشون من الهزات
الارتداديه حتى يوم امس قالت السلطات ان
انها رصدت اكثر من 790 هزه ارضيه وبالتالي
هذا يشكل خطر كبير
وانتم متواجدون هناك
نعم بالفعل شعرنا بهزات ارتداديه تحديدا
في غازي عنتاب صباح هذا اليوم انا شخصيا
يعني شعرت في هزتين وثلاث هزات ارضيه لكن
هنا في هذه المنطقه الى منذ ساعات وصولنا
حتى هذه اللحظه لم نشعر في هزات ارتداديه
بكهرمان مرعش حيث اقف على الاقل انا لا
ادري ان كان في مناطق اخرى ولكن لا ادري
ان كان الشخص الذي قابلناه قبل قليل
ظهر معنا على الهواء ام لا على اي حال
سمعنا قصته ايضا ولكن في نهايه الحديث
للاسف انقطع الاتصال معك
اذا ميسون كما قلت لك تتواصل عمليات
الانقاذ عمليات الاغاثه بالنسبه
للمنكوبين والمتضررين كما قلت لك هناك
مراكز ايواء وايضا يتم نقلهم الى مناطق
اخرى وولايات اخرى بعيده عن هنا مناطق
اكثر امانا يتم نقلهم جوا برا هناك يعني
طائرات عسكريه ايضا هناك ميسون خطوط
الجويه التركيه
تواصل
نقل المنكوبين وكما تشاهدين الان ميسون
يعني هذه سوره الجثه التي تم العثور عليها
قبل قليل ما زالت عمليه التعرف
يعني هل هي هل هو رجل هل هي امراه طفل
مسن اما لم نستطع ان نلتقي هذه لا ادري ان
كان ان كان يعني ممكن تحكي لنا اذا كان هو
رجل ام امراه او رجلين رجلين نعم ميسونهم
رجلان تم العثور عليهم وانتشلوا جثتهم
التعرف عليهم
هل يمكن ان تسالوا اذا تم التعرف عليهم
لا لغايه الان لغايه الامن للاسف لم يتم
التعرف على
الجثتين وبالتالي ربما
يعني الى ساعه من الان ان لم يتم التعرف
عليهم ستطبق سيطبق عليه البروتوكول وهو
الاحتفاظ بجسته لمده 24 ساعه لمده 24 ساعه
ومن ثم اخذ عينه من الحمض النووي سنحاول
ميسون ان ننقل لك الصوره الى الجهه الاخرى
حتى حتى كنتم نقلتم الصوره دعني اذهب
مجددا الى زميلنا محمود الشكر يمان محمود
هل ما زلت معي هل تسمعنا
اي نعم نعم اكمل لنا
بفارغ الصبر لان درجه الحراره تدنت الى ما
تحت الصفر صحيح يعطيكم الف عافيه يعني
انتم توصلون الليل بالنهار لابراز الصوره
من هذه المناطق المنكوبه حقيقه محمود
بالنسبه لهذه المساعدات التي تابعناها معك
هل هناك من مساعدات اخرى متواجده في هذا
المركز
نعم بطبيعه الحال هذا المكان تحول الى
مركز ايواء هو الاول لهذه المدينه
لاكن معك سريعا المدينه التي نحن بها هي
اصبحت يعني على الارض الكثير من الاحياء
مدمره بالتمام والكمال
السكان المدينه باكملهم يبيتون في العراق
او في المخيمات حتى ان ايضا في هذه
الجامعه التي نحن بها والتي تمتد على
كيلومترات
مربعه هي تحولت الى مركز كبير للالاف من
المتطوعين والمتطوعات الذين ياتون من
المحافظات الاخرى وينطقون على مدار 24
ساعه نرى بام العين كيف يدخل 100 متطوع ثم
بعد ذلك يبدلون بمئه اخرى كان الضغط هائل
عند هؤلاء من اجل الوصول الى احياء لليوم
الخامس نحن ندخل بعد نصف ساعه ولا زالت
الفرق
بجهد بالتوازي ايضا هذه الفرق التي يقدم
لها ايضا الطعام والفرق اخرى تقدم لفرق
تعمل على الارض الطعام
والماكل والمشرب والقهوه والمياه الساخنه
هنالك مشاكل كبيره تعانيها المدينه كنت قد
استمعت اليك مع الزملاء في المناطق الاخرى
على الكهرباء هنا فقط الدوله حددت هذه
النقطه وامنت لها الكهرباء لان كل
التوتر العالي او خطوط الكهرباء في
المدينه هي متقطعه الاوصال وحتى ايضا في
النت اذا كان يمكن ان نذهب الى هذه الصوره
لا ادري مع المصور الى المقرف اخر نجد ان
سياره بث هذه السيارات اتت بها الحكومه من
اجل تحسين اداء الهواتف الخاصه بمعنى النت
هي خيارات توضع وترفع هذه
ترفع ايضا الات عندها لتقويه البث حتى
يعود
هنالك مشكله كبيره انك تجدين اعداد كبيره
تاتي الى هذه البقعه من اجل ماذا من اجل
تشريج التليفون بالطاقه الكهربائيه لانه
في اماكن كثيره لا توجد فيها طاقه
الاغاثه بالنسبه للبيوت محمود من خلال
متابعتك اليوم البيوت التي
لن تسقط هل ايضا اخليت تماما
عزيزتي القاعده الاساسيه في هذه المدينه
كما اشرت معك انه لا يوجد احد في هذه
الليله يبيت في منزله نحن قمنا على مدى
ثلاثه ايام بجولات على اكثر من عشره الى
11 حي وعينا عن قرب كل ما هو قائم من
ابنيه هو متصدع من الداخل ومنعت الشرطه
وكما يقولون هنا البوليس ان يدخل احد
اليها اما التي هدمت هي تعد بالمئات سويت
مع الارض كاملا
وهنالك احياء بكاملها كنا في ظهيره هذا
اليوم مع عدد كبير من الرسائل من تلك
المنطقه وعليه نحن نتحدث عن مئات الالاف
من الاتراك او ايضا العشرات الالاف من
السوريين الذين يريدون ان يؤمن لهم ولو
نصف في خيمه مع تدفئه وهذا ما شاهدناه هنا
كانت المشكله على المدى الاربعه ايام منذ
ساعه تقريبا كنا نجور في الاحياء الداخليه
وكنا نجتمع وناخذ رسائل مباشره لعائله
سوريا باكملها لا زالت في العراق يعني ليس
هنالك خيم لها هي فقط السماء فوقها الارض
تحتها وبجانبها كومه من الحطب على مدار 24
ساعه ولكن ايضا بالمقلب الاخر هنا
او خيم قريبا ام لا محمود
هنالك وعود يبدو الى ان الاجنده او الجدول
لدى السلطات التركيه هو جدول ان تبدا
بالاتراك باهل المدينه ثم بعد ذلك ينتقلون
رويدا رويدا الى الوافدين الى اليها او
الى الناحيتين اذا صح التعبير وهذا ما
ينفذ على الارض نرى الان الى ان الجل
الاكبر هو اصبح في الخيام هنالك الالاف
بقوا خارج الخيام هنا هذه المشكله بالضبط
يعني
خمس دقائق ونحن معك ننتظر درجه الحراره
الاباء لاولاد السوريين قالوا ويقولون لنا
كيف نحن يمكن لنا ان نتحمل مع ساعات
الثلاثه والرابعه فجرا تحت الصفر وكيف
الاطفال هو طيره الليل يتحسس الطفل ويوقد
له بالحطب هؤلاء المنكوبين كان الله في
المناطق لانه عزيزتي كان الله
كان الله في عوننا جميعا لانه في ليل امس
في هذه المنطقه التي نحن كادق من اعلاميه
بتنا فيها هزت هنا مع الساعه العاشره ليلا
وشعرت بالارض انت وثم بعد ذلك قرات انها
هزت هنا فهزت ايضا في لبنان وفي فلسطين
وفي سوريا وسقطت ابنيه في دمشق كما البعض
تحدث عن محمود دائما نتمنى السلامه للجميع
اشكرك الان سنعود اليك في النشاط اللاحقه
لاذهب شكرا الى قهرمان مرعش مع زميلنا
غسان العربيه غسان ما الجديد
غسان هل تسمعني
على كل حال نحن نتابع هذه الصور من قهرمان
مرعش حيث يتواجد زميلنا غسان ابو لوز
وزميلنا ايضا باسل كانوا نقلوا لنا منذ
قليل يعني انتشال جثتين لرجلين على كل حال
سنعود الى غسان فور جهوزه وانما الان
سنتابع ايضا ما لدينا من مواقف وايضا من
قدم لنا بعض المعلومات في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال منقذ الطفل الرضيع السوريه
انه سيتبناها ويتولى تربيتها مع اطفاله
بعد ان فقدت جميع افراد عائلتها الذين
قضوا في الزلزال بينما نجت عفراء وتم
انقاذها من تحت الانقاض
بالباقر قال لي تعال شوف الحرمه هاي تتعرف
عليها هي هي عم تدور لها فاجيت لعندنا قلت
له نعم هاي ام ردينه واحنا عم نحفر سمعت
الصوت من فرحتي والشده بلشت اصرخ واصيح
قلت لهم ابو ردينه عايش ابو ردينه شلت
التراب ان الطفل طلع طفل هو فكانت تراب
كله على وجهه وكل جسمه يعني فشلته وطلع
طفل قطعنا الحبل تبع الصره وقلت انا الله
يرحمه ابو ردينه راح هو وعيلته اريد انقض
الطفله ورحنا به على مشفى بعفرين مشفى
جيهان وحطيتها بالمشفى هونيك ورجعت لعند
ابوها وامها كفينا ضلينا نحفر حتى طلعت
ابوها وامها واخواتها ودفناهم بدها تضل
عندي لانه عمتها انا ياخذ عمتها يعني وانا
ابن عم ابوها يعني بدها تضل عندي التربه
انا عندك لا تخاف
طلع لي
لا تخوف تمام
معلش معلش يا خالو معلش وانا
معلش
تحديات وعوائق وتواجهه عمليات انقاذ من هم
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه تحت انقاذ
البنايات المهدمه جراء الزلزال العنيف
الذي ضرب مناطق واسعه في جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا وكلما مرت الساعات تزيد التحديات
التي تحمل ابعادا لوجستيه وتنظيميه وغيرها
من العوامل نتابع بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
من تحت ركام المباني ترفع اياديهم طلبا
للنجاح الانقاد وان ثقلت ليست وحدها
العائقه امام الخروج بين الارض والسماء
عقبات اخرى تقف حائلا بينها عنصر الزمن
كلما مرت الساعات والايام تتضائل فرص
انقاذ من هم اسفل حطام البنايات في سوريا
او في تركيا سباق مع الزمن فوفقا لدراسات
بحثيه تعد الساعات الاربع والعشرون الاولى
هي الاهم لانقاذ الضحايا وبدء من اليوم
الخامس تتضائل فرص الانقاذ نظرا لغياب
عوامل التنفس والماء والهواء لكن
الاستثناء والامل يظلان حاضرين مثل ما حدث
في زلزالي اليابان وهييتي تسييس الازمه
التجاذبات السياسيه قد تؤثر على وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا وتقف حائلا امام فرق
الانقاذ عوائق دفعت اطراف الازمه دوليا
واماميا بالدعوه لتنحيه السياسه جانبا
يجب الحرص على ان لا تكون هناك اي عوائق
تؤخر ايصال المساعدات لانقاذ حياه الناس
في سوريا
الدعم والامداد امدادات من هنا وهناك
وتضامن دولي لكنها ليست كافيه لزياده
اعداد الناجين من تحت ركام المباني
نوعيه المساعدات والامدادات تحتاج الى
تدقيق فتظل اليات الانقاذ المتخصصه في هذا
الشان ومصادر الطاقه اللازمه لها لا غنى
عنها الطقس هطول الامطار في بعض المناطق
وتجمد الطقس في مناطق اخرى شكل خطوره على
العالقين تحت الانقاض والاسواق ان الاوضاع
الجويه السيئه عرقله وصول فرق الانقاذ
غياب التنسيق تدفق لفرق الدعم من مختلف
انحاء العالم ومساعدات تنطلق نحو سوريا
وتركيا من كل اتجاه لكن التنسيق مع جهات
الاغاثه يتطلب معلومات وحصرا لاكثر
المناطق تضررا فيما تبقى مواصله الجهد
الامل الوحيد في العثور على مزيد من
الناجين علي السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]
كل
الليل سلامتك يا روحي
[موسيقى]
يلا هلا بتنامي يا عمري
ارفع الباب
[موسيقى]
وننتقل الان الى كلمه مع نائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد اوكتاي نتابع ايضا موضوع
المواصلات موضوع ايضا نعير اهميه كبيره له
والطاقه وايصال الغاز الطبيعي
ايضا يتم ايصال شبكه الكهرباء بشكل حذر
طبعا
وكما قلنا سابقا ان
والشبكه التيار الكهربائي والغاز الطبيعي
يتم وصلها بشكل تدريجي
وطبعا بشكل حذر ودقيق
وايضا بالنسبه للمحروقات والوقود
الان بدانا بضخ كميات كبيره من الوقود
فيما يتعلق
مشاهدينا النائب الرئيس التركي يقول بانه
ارتفع عدد القتلى الى
17,674 قتيلا وبالنسبه لعدد الجرحى وصل
الى 72 الفا وكان يوضح طبعا ماذا يجري على
الارض وابرز المعوقات والتحديات وطبعا
يعني يعطي وصف لما يجري الان ان كان من من
مهمات لعمليات الانقاذ وايضا ما تعاني منه
بعض المناطق المنكوبه مهمات عده مشاهدينا
القيت على كاهل عمال الانقاذ منذ حلول
الكارثه على سوريا وتركيا فبين عمليات
البحث والانقاذ محادثات تريح قلب منتظر او
تهون عليه المصيبه نتابع
ارهاق بدا يظهر على وجوههم نوبات بحث
متواصله انهكتهم فعلا لكن الاشد ارهاقا
تعاملهم مع العالقين تحت الركام ومن
ينتظرهم في الخارج
ثلاثه ايام من عمليات البحث كانت مهمات
عمال الانقاذ خلالها كثيره ولم تقتصر فقط
على الحفر سواء بالايدي او المعدات
هؤلاء كانوا حضنا لامهات واباء اثقلهم هم
الفقد وتحولوا كتفا تكئ عليها الجميع عند
وقوع الفاجعه الله يصبر
قل لا اله الا الله
طمانه المنتظرين خارج المباني المدمره شيء
لكن ملاقاه اطفال لفهم الرعب لساعات وحتى
ايام شيء اخر
الله اكبر تكبير في البدايه نعم اي بعد
سماع النفس ورؤيه وجوه تتكلم تلهي دعابه
او اي كلمه قد تزيح عن مسرح طفولتهم مشاهد
خوف وذعر ولو للحظه كما يزاح الغبار
المتراكم على اجسادهم
يعمل
حكى
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بعد الانقاذ تبدا معاناه البحث عما يطفئ
اجساد الناجين وماوى يقيهم البرد لا يسمع
ني كابوس الماضي يلاحق عمال الانقاذ
السوريين صور حرب ارادوا مسحها من ذاكرتهم
بفعل تقادم السنين لكنها اليوم عادت وبشكل
اقصى
اظهرت صور حصريه للعربيه استمرار عمليات
البحث والانقاذ في مدينتي حارم وسلقين في
ريف ادلب واللتين تعرضتان لدمار كبير سكان
المدينتين وكذلك
المتطوعون
يستخدمون كل الوسائل المتاحه في محاوله
باتت خجوله لانقاذ عالقنا تحت الانقاض بعد
مرور ثلاثه ايام على وقوع الزلزال
بايديهم وارجلهم وكل ما تيسر من معدات
يقاتل السوريون في احدى معاركهم الكثيره
سكان ومتطوعون يسابقون الزمن في مدينتي
حارم وسلقين اكثر المدن المتضرره من
الزلزال في ادلب
عمليات الحفر والانقاذ مستمره فيما وقعت
على عاتق الكثيرين المهمه الاثقل وهي
انتشال الجثث ومرافقتها سواء لتسليمها لمن
بقي من العائله او للمشافي قبل الدفن
الغصه تكبر حين رؤيه الدمار من اعلى رغم
قساوه المشهد على الارض مبان سويت بالتراب
واخرى باتت عاريه لا تسترها نافذه او باب
او حائط لكن حتى تلك يخشى ان تحوي في احدى
زواياها شخصا عاجزا عن النزول حيده
الزلزال فعليق في برد دون كسوه
عواصف شتاء وثلوج ونوبات بحث متواصله
انهكتهم حينا لكنها لم توقف مسعاهم
عالقونا قد يكونون بانتظارهم منذ وقت طويل
وملت اجسادهم الانتظار
معارك الانقاذ الدائره في المناطق
المنكوبه في سوريا وتركيا يقابلها معارك
صمود تحت الحطام الا ان بعضها بات في حكم
الخاسر في السباق مع الوقت فوافق خبراء
كوارث تقل الامال بانتشال احياء بعد مرور
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه من وقوع الزلزال نتابع
72 ساعه توصف بالذهبيه انتهت والنافذه
الاكثر احتمالا لانقاذ ارواح شارفت على
الاغلاق وفق معظم خبراء الكوارث
فالوقت ليس لصالحهم بل يضعف الامال بسحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاض احياء
تعال عند خالك
تعيير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا اله الا الله اصوات خرجت من تحت الركام
في الايام الثلاثه الماضيه بعضها لحقتها
يد المساعده واخرى صمتت تدريجيا بعد ان
اتعبها ثقل الحطام وقسوه البرد فخسرت
المعركه نحن نسمع صوت من تحت الالقاب نسعى
جاهدين باتجاه ان نصل الى هذا الصوت ولكن
حقيقه البارحه يعني الوضع كان كارثي عندما
يصل الى هذا الشخص نجده قد فارق الحياه
عوامل اللوجستيه عده عرقلت عمليه الانقاذ
ضعف الموارد ونقص المعدات والاليات
المخصصه للرفع ادى لاوقات استجابه بطيئه
وساهم بزياده عدد الضحايا لينقل ناشطون
اقدام اشخاص على حفر التراب باظافرهم علهم
يعثرون على ناجين
قاتل ابن عمنا لمده 30 ساعه كنا نستطيع
رؤيته ويمكننا التحدث اليه لكن لم ياتي
احد من الحكومه
العواصف الثلجيه تضاعفه الكارثه مع ملامسه
درجات الحراره الصفر مع عرقل عمليات تتحدى
نقص الامكانات اصلا
نادت من اول لحظه بانها بان الكارثه اكبر
من القدرات الموجوده عند الفوز البيضاء في
حقيقه نقص المعدات يعني ادى الى للاسف الى
فقدان الكثير من العالقين وفقدان ارواحهم
قصص نهار لا يمحوها ليل بل يزيد فصولها
قسوه وتعذيبا اشخاص تمسكوا لثلاثه ايام
بسماع اصوات شاكيه وباكيه هرعوا خلفها ثم
حضروا لحظات اختفائها تدريجيا
ضعف وقع المصيبه
لندن بمختلف انتماءاتها تستجيب بسرعه
لتامين المساعدات لضحايا الزلزال عبر
تجميعها من الناس رغم ازمه كلفه المعيشه
التي تضرب البلاد المزيد في هذا التقرير
للزميل المصطفى زارو
هبوا بسرعه لمساعده الضحايا استجابه غير
عاديه من سكان لندن بمختلف انتماءاتهما
الدينيه والعرقيه لجمع المواد اللازمه من
بطانيات وحفاضات الاطفال والملابس الشتويه
ومستلزمات التنظيف والادويه لضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
من المدهشي رؤيه هذا الكم الهائل من
المساعدات رغمات تكلفه المعيشه المرتفعه
في البلاد جميع من شاهد اضرار الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا يريد ان يتبرع حسب امكانيه
الماديه او حتى بوقته لمساعده هؤلاء
المتطوعين
اطنان من مواد الاغاثه سلمها متبرعون الى
الجمعيه التركيه البريطانيه من بينها اكثر
من 200 جهاز التدفئه هؤلاء المتطوعون
يعملون على مدار الساعه لفرز كافه انواع
المساعدات وتقسيمها لتسهيل عمليه التوزيع
في وقت لاحق على المتضررين من الزلزال
ما نحتاج اليه بدرجه الاولى هو التوعيه
بالكارثه واشراك الناس اخبارها قد لا
تستطيع المساعده لكن يمكنك ان تعرف شخصا
يرغب في ذلك نحن حاليا بحاجه الى خيم لان
الناس هناك بلا ماوى
الناس يموتون من الجوع والبرد والحكومه
التركيه لم تقدم المساعده الكافيه وقريه
النورهاق تحديدا حيث يقطن جدي لم نسمع
منهما منذ ثلاثه ايام ولا ادري ان كان على
قيد الحياه او في عدد الاموات
هزال متطوعه تجهل مصير جديها اللذين كان
يعيشان في قريه دمرها الزلزال
هناك الكثير من الطلبه من الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا يساعدوننا بشكل كبير الى
جانب الجاليات التركيه بما فيها جامعه
سواس منذ اليوم الاول بجمع تبرعات مختلفه
من ملابس ومستلزمات ضروريه
مراكز عده فتحت ابوابها لاستقبال التبرعات
العينيه فيما تعمل جمعيات اخرى على جمع
التبرعات الماليه ومنها لجنه الطوارئ
الكوارث في بريطانيا التي اطلقت نداء
لمساعده مئات الاف المتضررين من الزلازل
التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا انتهت ولكن
تغطيه العربيه لهذا الزلزال وللمناطق
المنكوبه جراء هذا الزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا ما زالت مستمره ولكن نتابعها الان
مع زميل راويه في امان الله